結果なんですけども
待て、はじめ
ここで実は書けなかったなんて言うとまた怒られてしまう…
母ちゃんに　　ここは何とかして嘘をつかなければ…
どうしよう　どうしよう
そうだ！　実は出来たことにしよう！
そうしよう　そうしよう…
うっ、うまくいきまし/（汗）…
ちゃんとですね、ノートを作ったんですよ…
ノートを作って　ホントマジな方で勉強したんですよ…
字が汚いのはご了承願いたいんですけども
コツコツやりまっくたんですけども、
ん～～
際どい所だと思う。
正直際どい所だと思うよ
なんか最近月曜日は緩いですね。
というわけで何とか一応僕の今までの
小学校中学校高校大学ときて
学生生活最後のテストが今日終わりました。
あのね…複雑な気持ちです。
複雑！ぶっちゃけて言うと
書けるか書けたかっていうと
微妙なところです。一応全部埋めたし
勉強もしたんで、話は分かるんですよ。
ただね、おいらの出席日数
とかの兼ね合いとかもあるから、
そこらへんで単位がとれるかどうかってのが微妙なところなんですよ。
いや、ホントにわかんない。マジで単位とれたかどうかが
ホントにわかんないんで、ちょっと昔の動画でも言ったんですけど　も
単位が取れているかどうかはちゃんとこの動画で言います！
結果が出るまでもう少々お待ちください。
まあこの後僕が社会人に成るか成らないかはこのテストの結果によってなんですけども
やっぱなんか悲しいですね。もう学生が終わるので、
こーうもうなんかヘラヘラもしていられないなって思ってきました。
いや、まてはじめここでヘラヘラして居られないって言ったらもうヘラヘラできなくなる
いや、まてダメだ～そうだ！もっとへらへらしよう！！
遊び放題だ！！いぇぇーーい‼‼‼‼‼
さぁ、ちょっとどうなるのかな…
というわけで、今日はちょっと、今後のお話をしようと思います。
まて！
ここで今後の話をしてもしも卒業できなかったら最高にかっこ悪いぞ…
どうしよう…ここは…‼ここは‼‼どうしよう…
まぁいっか笑ダメだったらダメだったらでその時考えるよ！
とりあえず、今後なんですけども、大学を
卒業してはじめさんはどこにいくの？ってよくきかれるのですけども
うーん…
まだ決めてません！まだ決めてません(-_-;)
何処に行ってもいいんですよね～
一応候補としては静岡に、静岡に居続けるか
東京に行っちゃうか、
富山県＝実家の方に帰るか、この3つぐらいだと思うんですけども
まだ決めてないです。どこでもいいなと思っているんで…どうしようかな…
アンケートで決める？アンケートで決めちゃう？？
みんなのアンケートで俺の住むとこ決めちゃう？？？
いやだ！
ひとまず卒業できるかどうか決まってから場所を決めようと思っております。
そんなに焦ることでもないので
もう47都道府県でダーツで投げたところに住むとかでもいいかもしれないですね
しないけどな。
はい、というわけでしばらくはね、なんかすぐこの生活が変わることはないと思うんですけども、
え～待って～ほんと大丈夫だったのかな～
すごく不安なんですけど…
読めないな～読めない！読めないけどもまぁ成るように成ると思っております。
それと何か具体的に何をするかていうのはちゃんと卒業が決まってから話そうと思います。
これホントにちゃんと答えて卒業できなかったらほんとにかっこ悪いからね！
ちゃんと卒業が決まってから言おうと思います。
ポルトガル語のテスト皆様から結果どうだった？ってよく聞いてくれたので、
ポルトガル語は…
微妙でした
もうほんとに結果が分からなくなってきた…
僕が卒業できるかできないかはポルトガル語にかかっております。
まぁ、ひとまず僕が学校で勉強をするっていうのは今日で終わりでございます。
学生が終わっちゃうのか…
なにかいろいろ考え深いことはあるのですけども
まぁ、それよりね今後何が僕を待っているのかていうのがちょっと気になります。
ちょっと、テストで疲れているのでちょっと緩い動画に成っちゃったんですけども…
今学生の皆さん勉強ができるうちに勉強しえおきましょう。
大切な時間を過ごしてるわけだからね
べんきょうっていうのは今しかできないから。
時間のある時にたくさんやってみてください。
以上！！今日のメインチャンネルでした！！
ね～さみしいな～寂しい…
学生が終わるのは寂しいけど…まぁ頑張っていきます！
次回の動画でお会いしましょう！！
じゃあな！